how about a little relationship advice
boys yeah you're helping people one
relationship at a time man okay fine
Derek we'll do everything you want to do
Derek
all right this is Nick from Boston sup
deal it's all branding name's Nick from
Boston need some relationship advice
right so I got this done I just might
even be a 12 out of 10 but yeah bro but
the commitment type person right now no
no she is either okay right now you're
not got us together like I said she's
smoking so uh I killed I know what you
guys think
I'm 25 kind of at that point but like I
could sell down but I know if I really
want to you know how it is so yeah the
robot 39 and I'm at that point wise for
wisdom masters over there oh and
Britain's never been here all day just
some tear up a little mini smile and
some dark times and I appreciate that
gangbang buzz aldrin I love this guy oh
you be my friend I love him I think I'm
bossy in January brother we got a
meet-up free tickets on me but bring
your time even if it's not what yeah um
man twenties 25 she's a nurse she's 25
but is she 25 you didn't say what she
was but she's a nurse isn't her and
she's a dime lock it up brother twelve
will I'll be the judge of that
but a twelve and she's a nurse that mean
she takes care of people yeah she sounds
nice bro sounds pretty cool and even if
you're not ready to lock it down right
now at least uh you know at least start
fabricating the key I think a little bit
you know you could start to think you
know at least treat her well so you got
an opportunity down the line with here's
the thing though down the line fish like
that they get picked up real quick she's
gonna be ready down the line you know
I'm saying have you know a shitty and
she's at 12
everywhere she goes every dudes trying
to [ __ ] her so eventually some dudes are
told and they are what they are
chin see thanks for uh here's a pussy's
this your boy here dude lock it up it's
what she's a 12
urinating someone's gonna lock it up or
you know what don't listen the guy who's
married with two kids
listen of a single guy and this crazy
ass yeah was high case arrest my kids
yeah whoo - what was your case dude -
lock it up okay or it was don't lock no
no I said to lock it up my whole thing
I'm saying lock it up here's what I'm
saying down the line it could happen
make sure you stayin good contact that
jingoes I agree
don't listen to them they're all singles
[ __ ] well look I'll tell you this
Randall what's his name Nick Nick sorry
dude yeah rant Nick I usually I grew up
with a kid named Nicholas Randall
actually ended up being honestly
homosexual but I'll say this to your
brother is that yeah if you think she's
the one but you said she's still running
around so unless you could put that
squeeze in her you know unless you could
get that in her little baby bear and hit
her up with that gasm and get you a baby
then you might have a tough time one way
to lock down a real hot chick is to get
her pregnant you know you could do that
man
I said old school move bro it's like
you're hot yeah well here have a baby
but then nine months she's back to being
real hot yeah but she's got an H it's
just H own outside h.o.t yeah you right
yep
you mean ho I just mean it's like you
know it's just yeah there's some more
priorities you can't always put a B yeah
you can't put that little uh you know
you can't say chill anymore yeah it's
Netflix and children good luck dude keep
touching me though high your button
doesn't work bro
back up my broccolini get your life
together
I'm not touching